in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Tyler
and Caitlin are with us hey how are you
welcome welcome where you guys from
we're from Tyler Texas fun welcome to
Nashville we appreciate you making the
trip all the way over here to do your
debt free scream absolutely how much
have you paid off
we paid off $60,000 in 22 months way to
go making what kind of money we started
at around 33 and we're now at 75 okay so
in two years how do you double your
income we started with one single income
oh okay
and then worked our way up to both of us
actually working so she puts you to work
okay we have a bunch of jobs we had like
11 different job oh my gosh within a
year what do you do now so I work two
jobs still so I work at a Christian camp
in East Texas and I worked as a licensed
professional counselor intern oh cool
okay and what about you Caitlin I work
at a place called the mentoring Alliance
I basically get to facilitate
relationships between kids and families
in the community to provide tangible
help and eternal hope very good good
mission statement well done good so what
kind of debt was the 60,000 it was all
my that would be Tyler that's a student
loan debt yes all of it very cool what's
your degree in counseling
yeah I have a master's in counseling
that's the internship yes correct
yeah so that you now you can get awesome
licensed by the state of Texas after the
intern that's the hope that's the hope
still working and grinding them out yeah
very good cool yeah so what happened 22
months ago that starts your story just
before that we got married and I picked
up a book by a guy named Dave Ramsey for
a couple dollars at a thrift store there
you go and I read it and decided that it
was time to stop living like I could
spend whatever money I wanted and I
started living on a budget and then we
started doing that and I'll surely
thereafter when he got married and that
was really the kicker the marriage piece
was like oh gosh I should pick
this out I'm not by myself anymore it's
a whole growing up thing that happens
there right so Caitlyn he's reading a
book from a thrift store from a crazy
guy you're dating this guy and he starts
saying all this what did you say you
know when we when we were dating and
engaged Tyler I mean he's a free spirit
but he's very calculated he kind of had
the attitude of Caitlyn your parents
taught you how to handle money you can
do that you just take care of it but
when we got engaged and he got that book
and I think he probably sat down I
remember him going over to an Amer
amortization chart and seeing how long
debt was going to take to pay off and
I'm not kidding you once he read the
book and and drank the kool-aid he has
been the most intense gazelle-like
person I have ever met so I I am you
know pretty disciplined and standard in
that but he's been the one to say no
we're doing this we are in it to win it
and we're not quit until we're done so
you are being a disciplined person on
the natural league and coming from a
family handle money well I'm that kind
of you were not unhappy to see this
change in your fiance
oh this was huge really great it made it
easy for me to be able to follow like
when he took the lead and and took
responsibility for that I mean he was so
active and then saying here's what we're
gonna do we're doing it together so I
didn't feel like I you know had to jump
on board but it that's been a huge thing
in our marriage even learning we are a
team and we get to do this together yeah
it's very cool yeah so what is the what
do you tell people the secret is they
hear you paid off sixty thousand dollars
in debt in less than two years that's
impressive and they say how did you do
that Tyler says you say yes to free
things but on top of that we said no to
really good things a lot the secret
sauce behind that was having a plan
being able to sit down together and go
how are we going to tell our money what
to do this month how we're gonna even
gameplan for the whole year annually
what do we want to do and live on a
written budget live below our means and
really plan for the future and that's
now yeah
so a master's in counseling you're gonna
spend your life and are already spending
your life showing other folks how to
modify their behavior that's great and
you modeled that beautifully here how
much of your education the things you
had learned becoming a counselor did you
end up applying to this process quite a
bit actually being able to set goals and
make them SMART goals that they're
achievable that they're not just these
vague things that I hope to do but
rather there aren't they're in writing
and actually be able to track when I get
there and I do that a lot with my
clients and being able to help them see
oh we actually got here and be able to
celebrate that win and not just move
past it whether it be let's have a coke
when we would normally take water you
know those small victories or grabbing a
frosty you know when we would normally
not so we don't want to celebrate along
the way it was huge yeah absolutely I
would add to that that the whole process
of paying off debt for for us I think
was just I mean it's horrible and I hate
it and we're so glad it's gone but the
fact that we are now debt-free is a gift
not only that we have that financial
freedom to give away now but the whole
process of getting to where we are
absolutely was what I needed in order to
learn how to communicate with him so I
mean it did way more for our marriage
you know if finance is one of the big
things that you fight about we we fought
about how to communicate about finances
but we knew that there was a plan and we
were following it so I really think that
was a tool that was used in my life to
learn how to express what I need and
what I feel and and it was just
counselor over here he did a great job
well well said well said well done you
guys excellent excellent
what was the biggest fight you had
during the 22 months oh gosh I don't
remember what it was about but I do
remember we were on the side of the road
pulled over because I was crying so much
he got out of the car
pulled off an icicle from a street sign
and put it under my eyelids so that they
weren't so swollen I read I'll tell you
that much
it was ridiculous and we laughed a dear
crazy
and who knows what it was even about but
everything can get so tense when you're
you know battling this weight that's on
you yeah
so mr. icicle what was it about I wish I
could remember very cool and your mom
and dad are with you so obviously
they're proud yes yeah you so you had
some cheerleaders in your corner
yeah both sets of parents apparently
yeah absolutely they were all in our
corner
cheering us along the way and and now
even just to celebrate with a trip to
Nashville and seeing a little Billy
Gibbons tonight hopefully yeah well he's
a good guy he's a Texas guy so what's he
he comes up here occasionally in plays
though good stuff all right well fun fun
good for you guys all right Tyler and
Catelynn from Tyler Texas $60,000 paid
off
22 months making 33 now making 75 count
it down let's hear a debt free scream
three two one
love it love it love it well Don you too
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show I want to write a song I want
to own my own business I want to make
more money
those aren't goals those are wishes my
New Year's resolution is to make more
money this year to wish